dia todos e
como bola falou
gustavo borba
os transplantados é uma banda que surgiu
o ano passado 2014 a a partir de uma
coincidência
uma coincidência que eu não acredito em
coincidências na verdade eu acho que o
universo planeja coisas bacanas pra
gente e 2013 por coisas do destino
bebeto alves quentin e eu passamos por
transplantes de órgãos
eu fiquei dez anos na fila de espera de
um rim
bebeto transplante do fígado 15 e também
por questões de partir de ser e quando a
gente ficou bacana e conseguiu voltar à
vida normal ea vida é muito mais que
normal depois do transplante
ela é normal existe vida depois do
transplante é muito linda
a gente resolveu se juntar a gente já se
conhecia muito tempo nunca tinha tocado
juntos deverá se juntar porque há a
sensação que fica depois de uma
experiência a gente passa como essas é
de muita gratidão às pessoas que
permitiram que a gente continuasse
vivendo as famílias dessas pessoas que
doaram os órgãos para nós que permitiram
isso porque não sei se vocês sabem bater
legislação nacional a quem libera a
doação de órgãos em última instância é a
família
depois que a gente quando começou essa
história da banda de blues o princípio
tocar músicas nossas que a gente já
tinha prontos pois decidiu que não
queria fazer um trabalho com canções
novas tocando nesse tema
botando a mão na ferida e se engajam
nessas campanhas de doação de órgãos que
têm por aí com várias entidades
a gente tem feito coisas com a carta por
exemplo que eu tenho uma arma uma
campanha muito bacana cultura doadora né
são aulas shows com o médico dando
palestras estão a gente fala depois um
pouco das nossas experiências e enfim a
gente se engajou nessa história da
doação porque é uma coisa
importantíssima que o objeto faz um
pouco sobre isso também
por favor fale um pouco da importância
dessa
não na verdade eu acho que o mais mais é
não importante mas o que o resíduo disso
tudo na vida da gente é a questão da
generosidade humana e de repente num
momento de perda numa família se pensar
ainda na possibilidade de de entrega da
vida de uma outra pessoa
eu acho que pra nós que sofremos esse
trauma vamos dizer assim é de tudo um
transplante é essa talvez seja a parte
mais difícil né de conviver com esse
processo nesse processo todo porque
existem questões existenciais e
filosóficas que envolvem isso né
no momento em que tu pensa que alguém
teve que falecer prato continuar vivo
não que isso seja culpa de uma pessoa
que recebe um órgão mas é um bom eu sou
merecedor disso e por ser merecedor
disso tem que fazer que isso com que
isso vai valer muito a pena
então eu acho que esse é o sentido de
nós termos nos reunido e como de me
falou expressar nossa gratidão a
gratidão à generosidade humana
a gratidão às pessoas que pensam na
outra pessoa no momento tão difícil que
é o momento da perda
existe nós aprendemos muito estamos
aprendendo muito nessas ações que a
gente tem se associado à entidade
instituições como a do e carta que a
gente está junto com médicos que dão uma
aula técnica e informações importantes
para as pessoas a respeito do
transplante a gente recebeu uma
informação muito interessante que é
legal vocês saberem
é que a possibilidade de todos nós
qualquer um de nós é precisar de um
órgão é muito maior do que todos e
doador e ser uma coisa que nos faz
pensar muito né na questão da doação a a
gente sabe o que significa o sofrimento
da fila do transplante
e eu acho que é o grupo se forma com
essa intenção não há intenção de se
engajar realmente uma campanha e que a
gente consiga fazer o mínimo possível
pelo muito que a gente ganhou de poder
continuar vivo de poder desenvolver a
nossa música de poder tá cantando para
vocês que eu quero agora é bom não tem
muitos falaram bastante sobre o assunto
tem muito que falar eu acho que a gente
tem que conversar sobre o assunto em
família principalmente isso a gente
tenta passar essa idéia é acabar com a
fila
a gente não tenha a altura eo hábito de
falar sobre morte né quando é pequeno
nas escolas ou em família porque é um
tabu é um certo tabu mas a morte também
faz parte da vida então é necessário
conjetura a respeito
isso significa por exemplo no caso do
transplante que nos temos uma parte de
outra pessoa vivendo na gente dentro da
gente a gente é muito grato por isso a
gente vai cantar algumas coisas
falando sobre esse assunto
bbb10
eu sei que é difícil falar sobre isso e
família
mas é necessário colocar no assunto
nos meus olhos falou dem ter a tua visão
hum
teu coração
quem vai dividir
é com rita maria
e à medula de um outro salvado ante anos
um gol
não era o que eu cheguei
pra salvar o andré o pedro e também a
lucia
à flor da pele ela perde não vem cursar
a doação
o fígado não tem sexo nem ele
droga
o time for fun
e acredite na
o que mais importa
foi ninguém
isso não é livre obscene bola
adoro
e lá vi nada
além do treino
horizonte
ramsey vivo
arroz da célia pele não
o preparador nasceu
ei eu consiga tornar
é o senhor tem religião
e nós em droga
do ar puro
simplesmente em flor
e acreditar na vida e na
acreditar
o ano que vem
acreditar na vida e na um grande time é
o que mais importa
ele é
i
muito obrigado a sair será por canções
acabam falando mais do que qualquer as
canções para o melhor que a gente na
verdade a gente não fala muito bem a
gente vocês gostem falava cento ante 6
desconectado que 66 desarticulada hoje
por meia hora até mesmo disse leco
na canção alguma coisa no lugar como
essa por exemplo é a gente fez uma outra
agora pouco engajamos uma outra campanha
nos engajamos uma outra campanha que a
unicred e onde o slogan da campanha é
justamente tudo que a gente falou sobre
essa questão de expressar o sentimento
ea vontade ea necessidade de doação de
órgãos é o melhor instrumento é a voz ea
gente fez uma canção que justamente fala
disso ban a 23
o estado
ae
pra sentir o amor dá o teu coração ver o
pôr do sol
op
ozzy show
nessa canção
pra sentir a lesão e fez a limpa na
acima do chão
o rumor sem beber
acho um pouco de imaginação
vozes
só isso quem tem a voz é o melhor
instrumento é a voz pra falar que não
insano chora
isso
i
ae
a sanção
absurdo meu deus
o melhor instrumento é a voz
aqui não estamos sós pra cantar ia vida
e rosa e joão
a ação
bragança num uma nova canção
pra sentir no ar
tanto tempo
a produção
na tua visão cordas e vozes
né
é isso meu deus
ó pá pá pá e não estamos sós pra cantar
que a vila
isolando
i a
a tdt
hassan
cada instrumento
o melhor
é a dose na cauda que não estamos sós na
garganta que a vida
isolou
é do santos
nessa canção
o
não é isso lembrou
olha é obrigado obrigado foi um prazer